so I've been talking about the TSA as
basically security theater for years now
and really just sort of missing the bow
we really need psychological training
for our airport security staff I've
mentioned that at Tel Aviv Airport in
Israel they really seem to get it it's a
totally different story and I've spoken
about my experience there and you really
get the impression that the people there
actually know what they're looking for
as opposed to this myopic focus on
whether you have a hundred or a hundred
and five milliliters of conditioner or
whatever else the case may be and a
couple years ago I told you about a
self-test that the TSA did where they
tried to get banned items through sort
of to test their own effectiveness and
basically 95% of banned items got
through 19 out of every 20 banned items
were allowed through by TSA during self
tests of their security staff another
test was now done and this time roughly
80% of banned items got through the self
tests of TSA security what's truly
bonkers is that after the 95 percent
failure rate a couple years ago
supposedly major changes were made and
it's gotten the failure rate down but
it's still 80 percent does anybody feel
safer when they see the fact that 80
percent of banned items got through TSA
during internal self-tests of their
processes and security and of course
it's a total example of missing the
forest for the trees the new thing that
TSA is doing now the big big hubbub
around this is that TSA is going to be
using 3d imaging equipment so instead of
when your bag goes by seeing an x-ray of
your bag in two dimensions the system
will create a three-dimensional x-ray of
your bag so you can actually more easily
spot banned items or whatever you need
to completely upend the concept of the
TSA 2d or 3d screening is not going to
be what fixes the TSA producer Louis on
the show years ago told us the story of
how he got a knife on his carry-on he
forgot that he had this knife like a
four-inch blade on his carry-on and he
flew all the way to Arizona with it when
we went to visit a friend of our same
friend who got married
last month that I was down in Arizona
for and I also have a video up on
YouTube of me going through a TSA pat
down which I do every time I've never
gone through a porno scanner this is old
video of me look at how young I look
that's incredible
the entire video is available on YouTube
but I never go through the porno
scanners I don't believe it makes us
safer it is a big big it's sort of like
a giveaway to these big manufacturers of
security equipment that just make deals
with the TSA and make a ton of money so
you can see my pat-down video and it's
pretty funny and somebody tells my
girlfriend at one point to stop filming
and she says incorrect she said the
exact wrong thing which is it's for a
show that's the last thing you want to
tell TSA about why you're filming but in
any case you can find that video online
and this is you know I regularly get
through TSA security with larger than
allowed liquid containers not really a
big deal I'm not looking to do anything
with my soap or my shampoo or whatever
else that I'm bringing so we know that
TSA isn't effective at preventing items
on their own list of banned items from
getting through but we do know what TSA
is really really good at and porno
scanners are sort of a sign of that they
are really a great organization the TSA
for doling out huge amounts of money to
the security industrial complex the
contractors the equipment manufacturers
and there are tons of companies just
earning a ton of money working with the
TSA and there's this really common
argument and I know I'm gonna get it
because I mentioned it at the top of
this story people say David when you
talk about how Israel does it the u.s.
is too big we can't do it it's too
expensive to actually properly pay and
train everyone in TSA Israel is a tiny
country and whenever people say that
what I hear them saying is it's too
expensive to have good working airport
security so we're just going to settle
for the TSA which has been demonstrated
to be close to incompetent when it comes
to preventing items from their own list
from getting through what kind of an
argument is that that is a totally
self-defeating argument that will never
improve the situation with the
tsa you go through the porno scanners
Pat or do you request a pat-down or is
it does it yeah it's not a big deal to
me go through you go through the porno
scanner I always have to pull up my
pants
yes of course yeah well no that's that
that's for fun I mean that's not
required they just do that to mess with
you I have never gone through the porno
scanner and I will do everything I can
not to go through the porno scanner and
it's not because I enjoy the pat-down so
let me tell you every time I talk about
this I get emails David you just enjoy
being groped by a dude real clever
clever political analysis of the TSA
saying that I just enjoy the male
pat-down send me your thoughts what do
you think about TSA what should be done
with airport security in the United
States I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
hellofresh hellofresh is a meal kit
delivery service that shops plans and
delivers your favorite step-by-step
recipes and pre measured ingredients so
you can cook eat and enjoy with no
leftover ingredients rotting that you
eventually end up putting in the trash
can because in the end you don't know
what to do with the leftover ingredients
with hellofresh
the ingredients are delivered right to
you in recyclable insulated packaging
with pre measured labelled meal kits so
you know exactly which ingredients go
with which recipe and hellofresh offers
a wide variety of chef curated recipes
that change weekly including the classic
plan that comes with a wide variety of
meat fish and seasonal produce and the
veggie plan vegetarian recipes with
plant-based proteins there's also the
family plan quick and easy meals for the
entire family and better yet you can
also choose the delivery day that works
best for your busy schedule you can also
pause your account for weeks at a time
to suspend deliveries hellofresh makes
it so easy to cook delicious balanced
dinners for under 10 bucks a meal none
of those time-consuming meal planning
family adventures or grocery shopping
you can enjoy not spending money on
takeout for an easy night or worrying
about gathering ingredients week after
week and you can get 30
dollars off your first week of
hellofresh but you've got to go to
hellofresh calm and you need the promo
code the promo code is Pakman 30 PA que
ma n30 okay check it out you will love
it you will not throw out any food you
will have delicious food and it will be
done quick and easy hello fresh comm
promo code Pakman 30